[Music]
for morning rounds our look at the
medical news of the week first up we're
in the warmer months time when ticks are
at their most active and that of course
means more cases of Lyme disease it is
the most commonly reported vector borne
illness in the country meaning illnesses
transmitted from animals or insects to
humans according to the Centers for
Disease Control there are around 30,000
cases reported each year although the
actual number is likely to be much
higher in 2015 95 percent of these cases
were reported in 14 states a majority in
the Northeast and New England regions a
new study out this week in the Journal
of medical entomology examined a new
type of bacteria that can cause Lyme
disease here now to talk about this CBS
News chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook and CBS News contributor dr. Tara
Narula so John give us some idea what
did the study look at him what were the
main points that they found so here's
what they were trying to figure out how
long does this new species have to be at
does the tick carrying this new species
have to be attached to you in order to
transmit it the reason why that's
important is that the typical species
the tick has to be attached 36 to 48
hours before it gets transmitted so it's
very important to see is it the same
thing for this new species and they did
studies in mice and they found that yes
thankfully it has to be typically more
than 48 hours for there to be a
significant chance of transmission it
can happen rarely before then why is
that important well when my patients
call me which they did this past weekend
and say they have a tick on me one of
the first questions I ask is how long
was it attached to you if it was
attached for 36 to 48 hours or less than
36 hours then the odds of them getting
Lyme disease from it are very low and so
if it's more than that then there are
various strategies with antibiotics and
watching people for symptoms that can be
used to try to figure out whether you
should treat or not treat so Tara this
obviously now is the time and more and
more people are spending more and more
time outside so what kind of tips are
there for folks who are now hitting the
hiking trails right now I was just
thinking about this this weekend in
Connecticut when I was walking with my
five-year-old outside so you clearly
want to be outdoors but you can take
measures and be
particularly in these warmer months so
you want to stay in the center of trails
and really avoid those kind of high tall
grassy bushy wooded areas you want to
make sure when you come indoors you do a
full-body tick check you want to be
there shower typically within two hours
of coming in check your kids check your
pets check your gear make sure to use
repellent at least 20% DEET you can buy
permethrin treated clothing or spray
that on your clothing in gear and then
one other tip that John tonight we're
talking about is to tumble dry your
clothes when you come in on a high
setting for about 10 minutes and that
should kill any ticks the other thing
that the ticks are not shy everywhere
including where the moon don't shine yes
they like to crawl I enough said you
really have to look at every millimeter
of no really and no matter how much
prevention there is some are gonna get
through and there's so many different
symptoms give us some idea of the major
ones that people come up but one of the
things is that you know you get this
classic rash the rash of Lyme it can be
anywhere from 3 to 30 days it's
typically within a week or two not
everybody has that that rash you can
have aches and pains a flu-like illness
fever headache so if somebody seems so
normal that they see other and there are
a lot of times that people have these
viruses and it's it has nothing to do
with Lyme but I think a high level of
suspicion is very important and then
there are some other symptoms like you
can have neurological symptoms
especially later you can have a Bell's
palsy
we have drooping of one side of the face
you can have late symptoms you and we've
heard about chronic Lyme and and all of
that so I think the bottom line here is
you want to have a very high index of
suspicion especially if you're in an
area where you know that there's Lyme
right our next topic is equipping
yourself to hear better a newly
published research letter in the Journal
of American Medical Association compared
personal sound amplification products
with traditional hearing aids also known
as PSA PS they are less expensive than
hearing aids and can be purchased over
the counter however the devices are not
specifically labeled for hearing loss
treatment like conventional hearing aids
testing was done involving a group of 42
adults with an average age of 71 so
tarrying comparing these sort of new
devices with traditional hearing aids
what what did the research find well the
that we really need more low-cost
accessible options for people and that's
what these PSAP s are offering right now
and so when they compared them they
found that unaided speech understanding
accuracy was about 76% with hearing aids
that improved to about 88 percent with
the PSAP s that they looked at it
improved to about 80 percent so there
was some improvement but not to the
degree that it improved with hearing
aids in fact one of the five PS CPS they
tested what had worst speech accuracy
understanding so again this was a small
group of people it was only five
products the PSAP s that they tested so
we need a lot more research into this
and certainly more options for people
and it's actually not just the medical
community that's looking at it there's
bipartisan legislation surrounding
hearing aids right now yeah and it
they're looking at it right now and the
reason why that's so important is almost
50 million Americans have some degree of
hearing loss what getting behind apple
pie is yeah it's really easy less less
than 20% of people with these hearing
problems are actually having any kind of
hearing device something to help them
hear and the reason is it's expensive so
for Medicare for example you can it's
covered for you to go to an audiologist
an expert and say okay you need a
hearing aid but the hearing aid itself
which could be more than two thousand
dollars that's not covered so something
needs to be done yeah well let's finally
go to our last topic Medical Solutions
from the see a study published by the
American Society of microbiology looked
at the research for tuberculosis
treatments in ocean life a team of
researchers at the University of Central
Florida screen more than 4,000 chemical
extracts from ocean creatures like
sponges to see if they could find any
that might be effective against the
disease in fact they turned up 26
compounds that were effective against
replicating bacteria but they know they
have a lot more work to do studying them
in detail so what is all of this mean
well so many of our medications come
from plants yet another reason to
peacefully coexist good nature yes not
destroy them why did it like we needed
other reason doctors Jon LaPook and Tara
Narula thank you